para no hablar de un ganador y un
perdedor desde su perspectiva quién se
mostró más seguro y conocedor de lo que
en estos momentos centra la atención de
los franceses
muy buenas noches gracias por invitarme
bueno realmente yo creo que el debate
fue mucho menos tenso que hace cinco
años pero que claramente se vio un
dominio de los temas que le importan más
a los franceses por parte de manuel
manjón en varias ocasiones más en lepe
en tuvo que revisar sus cifras tuvo que
volver tuvo que éxito un poco en sus
respuestas o sea que yo realmente creo
que ahí no cabe la menor duda bueno y en
un debate como éste realmente puede
inclinar la balanza a favor de uno de
los candidatos realmente sirve para
conquistar a los indecisos
sí bueno eso es lo que se temía mucho
antes de que empezara el debate qué
imagen lo peleen mucho más preparada que
hace cinco años
fuera mucho más convincente ella también
ha beneficiado de una estabilización por
parte del candidato de extrema derecha
desde muy haciéndola ver a ella como una
un personaje un poco más o menos digamos
de extrema derecha entonces lo que se
temía era que este debate pudiera hacer
cambiar la balanza pero yo creo que toca
ser mi opinión personal que no fue el
caso que al final del debate los dos
candidatos enseñaron sus verdaderas
caras más european volvió a sus temas de
predilección que son la inmigración la
inseguridad y todo eso realmente les
permite a los franceses es situarse en
campos ya definidos o sea que no creo
que este debate haya realmente cambiado
el balance de la elección bueno con
estas propuestas que fueron expuestas
hoy de manera bastante directa es
probable que el open logre adoptar los
votos de ixe - de la primera vuelta y
mccann de los demás datos que de alguna
manera pidieron votar por él o dijeron
que ellos votarían por él
bueno el más grande desafío de manejo es
luchar contra los abstencionistas
porque obviamente que el voto de meloso
se divide en una serie de personas que
si van a votar por emma en el marco y
otros que ya han indicado que querían
abstenerse lo que si pudiera cambiar con
este debate es que al ver la verdadera
cara de ma jin noten al ver que los
temas
digamos clásicos de la extrema derecha
vuelven a estar sobre la mesa esos
electores indecisos pudieran cambiar la
idea y si poner un voto en la urna para
emanuel mejor pero aparte aparte de eso
yo pienso que los los digamos los
votantes que ya tenían pensado dar por
más en lópez todos los de semoy y una
parte de la derecha digamos más radical
no no no habrá cambiado de idea sino que
está confrontado en sus opiniones
sobre más